President Biden's classified document
drama putting the media and the White
House in a tough spot it was another
brutal day in the briefing room for the
press secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre
there's a dash between the last two
letters to has two words who refuses to
answer simple questions
why shouldn't Americans be upset about
documents found in a garage that's for
uh that's for the American people to
decide the president goes out and talks
to the talks of the American people they
also care about the economy on Friday
did you or did you not know about the
additional I already I'm literally just
answered that question
I mean you're you're not too far sitting
next to her so I was very clear I
provided I provided the information that
you all had at the time you guys can ask
me this a hundred times 200 times if you
wish I'm going to keep saying the same
thing I hear your question it's been
asked it's been answered it's been noted
oh my God and while some Democrats and
pundits have been harsh others are
making new excuses
national press can't help but make fools
of themselves that happened in
Whitewater it happened an email Scandal
and this happened now reporting uh
sometimes it's a little more Sensational
than it ought to be I used to be in the
business you know so I understand that
at the end of the day we could do a
whole media segment on the idea of
trying to be really aggressive when it's
a Democrat to balance out what people
feel like well maybe it's something
unfair no Donald Trump really did the
things he really actually did the things
wow all right and breaking news from The
Wall Street Journal this just into all
of us the doj is considered but decided
against having FBI agents monitor
research by President Biden's lawyers
for classified documents at his home
which is one question you had why do
they get to search themselves and then
hand over this stuff judge you were
commenting during this whole time first
off on the new revelation The Wall
Street Journal just has at the justice
department at the last minute next
having the FBI lead this you just asked
the question why do they get to search
their own records classified records
with private lawyers who don't have
access to that security clearance
because they're Democrats Hillary
Clinton can erase 33 000 emails Joe
Biden can move them around and here's
the problem with these with these people
who say we don't get it the problem is
you're dealing with a guy who's been
involved in sucking up money from all
over the world living with his father in
the house where these documents are
located and nobody's concerned about it
it's nothing to see here folks and then
you've got a pressed person who
literally is standing at the podium
saying I answer that question well I
didn't hear it what did you say yes or
no well as the person next to you and
then she goes on for five minutes saying
she answered it but she won't answer it
this is this is the Twilight Zone there
is no way that Joe Biden who has records
that are at least six years old that he
doesn't have the ability to access or
declassify himself now we've got lawyers
with other security clearance who will
invariably be called as Witnesses right
and we're it's going nowhere but you're
burying the lead the lead is that they
did ask the doj whether or not they
should have FBI agents accompany the
private lawyers who is somebody did the
doj apparently knew that the private
lawyers were searching and I think it's
on Merrick Garland what is Merrick
Island it really and who's
that Mary Garland is really partisan I
hate to come to that conclusion I know
but if he had if he pondered whether
fbin should accompany the private
lawyers and then said ah no you guys do
it that that to me is on Merrick Garland
not on Joe Biden I know a couple I know
you're ready to roll I just want to also
have to entertain This Dana the
administration came out on the offensive
they said let's go let's get him on
their Heels by saying hey why are you so
mad at us why haven't the Republicans
come clean on the deal they had behind
closed doors to give Kevin McCarthy the
speakership what kind of offense is that
right you've got to admire they're
trying right but it's just it's like why
don't we get involved in somebody else's
fight and the administration says they
can't be sure how many documents that
already been handed over because once
they saw they handed over they got
confused yeah and also it's like hot
potato it was like I don't want it I
don't want it I don't even have a
clearance I don't want to touch it
because I can only see the coverage so
they knew that it was wrong
um this you know the whole drip drip
drip thing worse than Watergate here it
comes the thing is they would love to
for this to go away but at four what 505
this evening is when you find out that
oh actually you have another angle to
the story so the White House Press
Secretary tomorrow can be sure that
these are questions are going to
continue and then she's going to have to
go up one side and down the other and
she's going to say that she won't
comment Mike McCurry during the Lewinsky
scandal had this great line in the Press
briefing room just to calm everyone down
he said look folks I'm double parked in
a no comment Zone and the reporters
laugh like nobody in the briefing room
today is left nobody they're mad they're
irritated they feel like they've been
given the run around they'd love to
probably cover another story too she's
not giving them any way to do that maybe
because she doesn't know like I don't
know if she at what point did they
inform her and is she playing catch-up
and you have to act almost as a lawyer
when you're the press secretary to say
okay well you're telling me this is true
now but none of this makes sense so what
are you going to tell me tomorrow that's
going to be different you have to think
ahead three or four days and you have to
say to them don't make me look like a
fool like I don't know what I'm talking
about because they already know based on
tomorrow they'll know that I should have
known right Greg you've been hearing a
lot of people go back and forth about
something American people care about the
pressures on you to say something we
don't expect well that's going to be a
tough challenge Brian by the way it's
great to have you here right yeah you
really mean that no I didn't think so I
don't who is he no I think you know
there will be the argument that that
says oh this is nothing you know and it
just might be nothing but that isn't the
point my the way I'm looking at it is
how do you prevent the future Hysteria
uh that we saw when the media Unleashed
uh this insane amount of press about
Mar-A-Lago or about Trump's taxes or
about the dossier and I and I always I
would do the argument oh we should be
better than that when it happens you
know we'll just we'll be the better
person it doesn't work being the better
person doesn't work you have to return
it in Spades so that way they learn a
lesson the next time they're about to do
something in which they go crazy about
something that's not there saying it's
worse than Watergate and so on they'll
remember well you know the Republicans
could do the same thing but it goes back
to who knew this who knew that this
stuff existed and when and did they hold
it back to influence an election so
right again wait let me finish Mr kill
me okay go ahead all right so did they
did they hold it back to influence this
election because there is precedence for
that and such precedence only goes in
One Direction Just Like The Wall Street
Journal thing it only goes in One
Direction so it is not about say the
objective
protecting the election from late
breaking fake News That's The Honorable
thing to do right it's like we don't
want to have this story affect the news
and then it turns out to be fake well
they didn't seem to mind at the Access
Hollywood tape so again their
interference only goes in one direction
if they had stopped or tried to kill the
Access Hollywood tape that would be
different but it was amazing how the
Press dropped that at exactly the right
time still didn't work but see you know
what the most amazing thing is we talk
about documents being highly classified
the highest level
can you imagine if what's in those
documents is the real story the fact
that they exist and they're in the wrong
place is a story can you imagine if they
reveal an investigation Ukraine there
you go we know Hunter Biden we will see
if we can actually find out what's in
them maybe that's why they said whatever
you do don't tell Joe what we found when
he said I don't want to ask what they
found in my garage or why it took them
two months from the time they first
found it to our final because if they're
in your garage then you should know
about it and you should you're the
commander-in-chief and you should do
something about it and doesn't that
demand the a early morning attack
because it is in your house there should
be a limit of 10 questions the same
question over and over again right
this is the most difficult close to a
segment I've ever done but I'm going to
try to lock it out I went on Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now